[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here this is
the pixel 4 xl this is one of the phones
i was looking forward to the most this
entire year for 2019 for a couple of
reasons and so now i've been using it
daily since it's unveiling
this is my honest review so let's just
start with the way it looks i honestly
think it's a pretty decent looking phone
it's low-key really clean there's almost
no markings along the back just the
google g at the bottom matte black
aluminum rails as part of the design all
the way around the phone speaker slots
at the bottom lined up with the usb
type-c port and the colored power button
of course on every version and the whole
back of the phone on two of the colors
is this soft touch matte finish which
does a great job of not showing
fingerprints it doesn't seem to scratch
very easily at all so of the three
colors available i'm gonna say this
white this panda version is the best one
that power button is pretty sweet then
i'm going to say oh so orange is in
second place not so great power button
but at least it's matte and then that
jet black
weirdly very glossy version is in third
place fun fact though since the rails
are still matte black you can slap a
matte black dbrand skin on the back of
any of these phones and you just created
the matte black everything phone google
should have made in the first place so
link to that below and of course shout
out to dbrand for sponsoring this video
the pixel square camera bump is again
annoyingly a little bit raised but i
don't find this as drastic as say
apple's larger double raised triple
camera bump but more on the cameras
later so yeah you know what generally
it's grown on me pretty decent looking
phone i was though let a little bit down
by the
not super clicky buttons just the volume
ones mainly but on the other hand
something a lot of people have missed
that's good to know the phone is now
ip68 water resistant it still has the
squeeze sensitivity for the assistant
and it still has stereo speakers so
they're not front-facing pair like they
were last year but they are still a good
sounding solid pair with the slots at
the bottom and the earpiece speaker
combined uh the worst part about the way
this phone looks is the front
the part you look at most of the time
i'm not a fan of the forehead it has a
smaller chin at the bottom than before
but yeah that big forehead i don't like
it
i'm still kind of barely getting used to
it and overall the reason for the
forehead
doesn't really have me convinced so
there's a cluster of new sensors up here
in the top including the selfie camera
then also infrared projector receiver
and radar which is new in any smartphone
and this new sensor suite up here is
good for two things the fastest face
unlock in any smartphone
and some gestures okay maybe it makes me
a little not forward thinking but
i still like fingerprint sensors and
this phone has none of that the face
unlock is the only biometric unlock this
phone has and i find myself missing a
fingerprint sensor and the rate of
improvement for fingerprint sensors
under the glass has been pretty good so
that move was not my favorite pixel 4
uses a radar sensor to essentially
project a little bubble around the phone
to see when things are near it when
things are in the bubble when they enter
it exit it etc so when you reach for
your phone basically your hand enters
the bubble and it starts firing up the
infrared and face unlock sensors early
so by the time you pick the phone up
it's already reading your face and
logging you in and it's incredibly fast
over and over again it's super
impressive
possibly too fast this kind of reminds
me of the oneplus 6 and other phones
that would just do face unlock with just
the rgb cameras so they'd be insanely
fast they would just see anything that
looks like you and just unlock as soon
as you glance at it so this isn't that
it's still infrared so it still can't be
fooled by a photo or video of you it
still works in the dark and things like
that so it's got advantages but it's
still a little bit wild i find myself
just unlocking this phone left and right
all the time anytime i even just look at
it sometimes i pick up the phone just to
move it across my desk and i'll just
glance at the time and it unlocks the
phone it also doesn't require your
attention so it will unlock with your
eyes closed
that's uh that's a bit of a weird
security quirk and it actually even
tells you it'll do this in the settings
when you turn this on it says looking at
the phone can unlock it when you don't
intend it to and your device can be
unlocked by someone even if it's held up
to your face even if your eyes are
closed and potentially could be unlocked
by someone who just looks a lot like you
these are things that could potentially
be fixed or improved with a software
update and google's been pretty good
about software updates but as of right
now they're just pretty annoying my
solution is turn off the skip lock
screen option so if i do accidentally
unlock it at least it won't be awake for
a while it just sits on the lock screen
and then it'll go back to sleep but yeah
i mean that's what i think i mean when i
say i would have liked a fingerprint
reader option it's a little safer we're
a little more used to it and it just
sort of works when we need it and
doesn't when we don't so that's face
unlock but then these sensors also
enable a couple very specific gestures
so anytime you're in a situation
you can wave over your phone and use the
gesture the status bar sort of lights up
it starts glowing and that means it's
ready so those situations are alarm
clocks timers
media controls and a pikachu live
wallpaper and there are no instructions
like really built into android there's
none in the android 10 setup for example
nothing really tells you what's going on
when you first get that glowing bar you
just kind of have to know so when an
alarm or a timer is going off as your
hand enters that radar bubble it quiets
the alarm and then you can dismiss it by
tapping or swiping away over the phone
that for me was my favorite it worked
really well i can sleep with my phone on
this pixel stand next to the bed and
when the alarm goes off i just reach for
it and it's already quieting down
the other thing that was less consistent
for me is music apps so if you're in
spotify or google play music or any
supported app where that glowing bar
starts showing up you can swipe forward
and swipe back
through previous and next tracks
and yeah that's it just
forward and backwards when i first tried
this at the event i was getting a
success rate of like
10 percent i'm not even exaggerating
like it was pretty abysmal now with some
troubleshooting and practice and some
tips from twitter i'd say i'm up to like
a 70
swipe success rate maybe 75 so it's less
of like a big arm movement although that
sometimes does work but it's more of
like a casual swipe and not too close to
the phone like right around where that
radar bubble
might be
i think the real problem is it doesn't
show you or tell you how to do it better
the made by google twitter account they
tweeted at me saying you can go to the
pixel tips app which is pre-installed on
the pixel click save time and then click
try it and then there you will find a
demo if you want to practice it
but even then there isn't actually i
tried it there isn't actually any
feedback it's just letting you practice
so all of that being said i'm still not
going to use these i it sort of falls in
that same gimmick bucket as the g8s
weird hover hand
swiping action
if it told me how to do it better maybe
i'd be more into it but yeah not going
to use these if there's anything to love
about the front of this phone it's the
new display pixel 4 and pixel 4 xl have
made the jump to smooth high-res
high-refresh rate 90 hertz displays my
favorite trend in smartphones of the
past year so it's difficult to show you
exactly how much better that looks
obviously i keep saying on camera
because this is a 30fps video you know
the correct frame rate but in person it
makes a huge difference and every time a
new phone comes out with a 90 hertz or
higher display i can see a serious
difference versus 60 hertz it comes with
some trade-offs though it's not the
brightest display sometimes daytime
visibility is pretty weak unfortunately
so i'm keeping this phone at max
brightness often
and high refresh rate also requires more
power so you're going to see a hit on
battery life now initially i was we're
all concerned about the battery life on
pixel 4 knowing it has a higher fresh
rate and then the xl having a 3 700
milliamp hour battery and the smaller
pixel 4 having a 2 800 milliamp hour
battery that's one of the smallest i've
seen in a phone in a while
but impressively
these phones have had
for me okay battery life but there's a
big reason for that i was briefly
messaging dave2d who's he's testing this
smaller pixel 4 and he said he's getting
around five hours of screen on time
which if i take his word for it that's
actually pretty impressive um for me
i've been getting
around five hours on this xl on 90 hertz
which
you know that's c plus which is a lot
better than the f i thought it could be
turns out the reason this phone has been
able to get even okay battery life is
because it ratchets down to 60 hertz
constantly
all the time it's supposed to be smart
about it so it says when you turn on
smooth display that it'll turn back down
to 60 hertz when you're not looking at
it or you're not using it much and then
ratchet it back up to 90 when you're
swiping or you see animations and stuff
but i found often it just stays at 60
hertz for extended periods of time for
no apparent reason it almost seemed like
it was defaulting to 60 hertz most of
the time and then sometimes bumping up
to 90 hertz for scrolling and some other
things i started to not like it i
started to find that this phone felt
significantly
choppier like any other 60hz phone than
say the oneplus 7 pro which seems like
it's almost always at 90 hertz so i was
like okay this isn't great it's not my
favorite implementation of 90 hertz it's
smooth sometimes but it's almost like a
tease that it switches back and forth so
much
so i'm like digging around in developer
options just to see if there's anything
new
and there is i found an option that i'd
never seen before it's called force 90
hertz and it just keeps the display at
90 hertz all the time no matter what's
happening on the screen closer to what
oneplus does and it's made a huge
difference now it's always smooth so i
guess pro tip if you're one of those
people who's more of a power user and
uses their phone all the time and wants
to see that 90 hertz happen you can go
in the developer settings scroll down
find force 90 hertz and turn it on it
will obliterate your battery life it's
definitely even worse now closer to a d
it's not lasting all day um but at least
it's
smoother now anyway i also found that it
has ambient eq which is supposed to be
auto adjusting the color temperature
depending on the light around you kind
of like apple's true tone on the iphone
but i found it much more subtle so i
just left it off it's not nearly as
dramatic and overall it's just it's not
the flashiest or most eye-catching or
dramatic display on any smartphone it
doesn't curve over the edges or anything
but it's 90 hertz it's 1440p
it's oled
and it's flat but listen we all know
what the pixel 4 is about it's what the
pixel 3 was about and it's what the
pixel 2 is about
it's the cameras and we got some new
cameras on the back
of the pixel 4. there's dual cameras
back here it's a 12 megapixel primary
camera and a new 16 megapixel 2x
telephoto camera um
okay if you told me the pixel 4 would
have the first second camera of any
pixel phone and asked me what would be
the most useless
second camera they could put in the
pixel
right behind like a black and white
depth sensor or a time-of-flight camera
i would have put
like a 2x telephoto lens just behind
like an ultra wide clearly being way
more fun or a 3 or a 5x telephoto or any
of that other stuff
but that's what we got we got 2x
telephoto but you know what specs are
just one thing i gotta actually use it
in person that's what i've been doing
maybe it'll change my mind
yeah it didn't really change my mind
typical photos from the pixel 4 are very
similar to pixel 3. great dynamic range
great sharpness and detail very
contrasty and punchy and dramatic
and biasing a little bit towards cooler
tones typically if anything but they're
excellent photos they've got this image
processing pipeline and their hdr down
to a science and that didn't shock
anyone thankfully so that's good
and the improvements in the viewfinder
are cool too you now have real-time
approximation of the hdr effect you're
going to get applied before you even
snap the photo so there's no guessing
you can pretty much just see what the
final photo is going to look like as
you're taking it plus there's new
sliders for exposure and shadow
adjustment that can be really cool and
you can mess with if you want but then
having a second lens should mean
portrait photos are better now because
you have two lenses and you can finally
do depth data between them
i found that they're about the same
matter of fact some of the ones i took
of mac here look worse than any i ever
took on the pixel 3. just look at that
cutout failure
that's pretty terrible maybe i shouldn't
depend on pet photos for my testing and
portrait mode but i'm not exactly
convinced by that but generally on
photos of people it's doing about the
same job with that aggressive cutout and
then speaking of portrait mode you
actually can't do
wide portrait photos anymore which the
pixel 3 took some of the best wide
portrait photos but it gets even more
double weird when you actually look into
it so pixel 3 took some pretty great
portraits with one wide camera right
when you switch to portrait mode on the
pixel 4 it automatically zooms in but
not quite to 2x to about 1.7 or 1.8 x
but then it doesn't let you zoom out and
take wide portrait photos like the
iphone does but as i'm messing with this
i realize if i cover the telephoto
camera while i'm in portrait mode
nothing happens it's still using the
main camera for portrait mode photos
it's just using the second camera for
depth approximation
so why does it zoom in
i have no answer for that so basically
the best thing about having a telephoto
camera is for zoomed in photos
i don't take a lot of zoomed in photos
but i did notice them higher quality so
if you're someone who likes to go 6 8x
zoomed in you'll appreciate the better
super resume there you go anyway the
question still is is this the best
camera in any smartphone uh because i
think we can all agree pixel 3 was top
of the stack last year but now the field
is catching up especially iphone 11 pro
so which is better
okay honestly in daylight for most
photos i prefer pixel photos i
definitely like that contrasty punchy
detailed look same with wide angle
selfies punchy detailed i'm a fan
in lower light though i actually start
to prefer iphone photos and i know the
pixel you know just got astrophotography
capabilities that are really cool and
night sight has always been great for
well over a year now but they get a
little more dramatic and as a result a
little more noisy and iphone's new night
mode and deep fusion i think stay truer
to life and as a result better in
quality fun fact i actually did a collab
that's live now with supersaf in one of
his legendary side by side photo
comparisons so that's the best way to
see the differences between the two so
you can see iphone 11 pro versus pixel 4
side by side in all of our glory i'll
leave a link below to that so is this
the best camera in any smartphone
sometimes i'm going to say it's a
toss-up depending on the scenario and
that's not a cop-out i gave my reasons
um but if i could only pick one which is
sort of a different question
i would pick iphone 11 pro because it's
more versatile it has the ultra wide and
it absolutely crushes it in video like
video is just not as much of a focus
with the pixel 4's camera anymore no pun
intended it tops out at 4k 30fps which
google tweeted is because it would
basically take up too much storage but
then like you could have still enabled
it in settings if you really cared right
and that also doesn't explain why it
doesn't have 24fps video which would
have been a cool addition and it also
tops out at 1080p from the front-facing
wide camera
so just generally if you're in it for
video you shouldn't be looking at pixel
you should be looking at iphone 11 pro
my pixel versus iphone camera graph is
like this pair of lines where the middle
is where most photos are taken most of
the time and that's where i prefer pixel
but on the edges of photography like low
light or ultra wide then the iphone does
better so there hopefully that
explanation makes sense and then you
can't forget android 10 which gets the
special treatment on the pixel since
it's google's baby there are some good
features here that add to how smart it
is as a smartphone you already heard
about the radar bubble and the smart
unlock features they move the
text-to-speech offline local on the
phone so text-to-speech is
way faster and way more consistent i
love that you can talk as fast as you
want and it just works and there's a new
voice recorder app that takes advantage
of that to live transcribe everything
you say and then indexes that text to
make it searchable that's like an s pen
level feature i personally probably
won't use it too much but i can see how
people who use that would find it a
really big deal but yeah the best part
of the pixel again is how refined
android is if you want the latest
version of android if you want to be
first with updates if you want the
coolest edge features and the assistant
and all that
is the phone to get so overall many of
the conclusions about pixel 4 are of
course about how disappointing it is
which i think is an easy conclusion to
reach if you followed all the leaks and
nothing really surprised you and there
are things that are let down i
personally really enjoyed using pixel
because of the punchy confident
excellent camera for still photos and
the 90 hertz display which a lot of
phones don't have yet and of course the
extra ram finally a smooth pixel phone
but this isn't a phone i'm going to go
around recommending to everyone it still
needs a bigger battery still needs more
storage
and it's just generally not complete for
most people so i guess if you're like me
which is in a tiny group of people who
really like high refresh rate screens of
course value the camera and want the
latest version of android and these
quick updates and things like that and
you're willing to overpay because we all
know the pixel is a bit overpriced for
the storage you don't get
then sure i recommend the pixel it's
great for people like that but for most
people
i'm not going to end up recommending the
pixel 4 mainly because of the battery
but also because there are just better
deals out there right now including the
cheaper iphone 11
weird to save but it kind of hits the
ear funny but it's true so there you
have it the pixel 4 possibly a victim of
the hype machine of being
the most leaked phone of all time
i kind of wouldn't be surprised if it
happens again next year
but either way now you know what it's
like to own it and i'm curious are you
in this tiny group of people who would
like this pixel experience
let me know
either way thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]